all right I just need everybody to see
this look at this look at this thing so
this thing is Samsung's new Galaxy Tab
S9 Ultra it's pretty similar to the S8
Ultra from last year but I mean it's
just so ridiculous I just needed to show
it to you 14.6 inch 120 hertz OLED
display Best in Class Snapdragon 8 Gen 2
for Galaxy which is an overclock chip 16
gigs of RAM up to a terabyte of storage
quad speakers and a pair of front-facing
cameras one regular and one Ultra wide
and it's all just so stupid thin like I
feel like if I brought this piece of
Hardware back in time long enough it
would just look ridiculous it just feels
like I'm carrying a monitor around and
there's some other Android tablets out
there having a moment right now you know
the affordable one with the OnePlus Tab
and the dockable one with the pixel
tablet this one is just the crazy one
which is why it's 1200 bucks I feel like
it's tempting to call this an iPad Pro
killer but I also feel like they're just
really different even though they're
both super capable also one tiny small
request Samsung please add 5G to the
ultra thank you